et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés marie roger biloa directrice
du groupe afrique international bonjour
marie roger sengel et bilal tarabet
chroniqueur internationale à la
rédaction de france 24 bonjour bilal
bonjour appel at il cherché à montrer
ses muscles à montrer son pouvoir de
nuisance note al assad heures l'espace
d'une journée le leader chiite irakien a
laissé ses partisans prendre d'assaut la
zone verte pourtant ultra-sécurisée dans
la capitale bagdad avant de les rappeler
à l'ordre c'était ce matin écouter
ce n'est plus une révolution
car elle a perdu son caractère pacifique
il est interdit de verser le sang
irakien
je crois toujours que le mouvement
sadriste et discipliné et obéissante
c'est pour cela que je demande à tous
ceux qui sont dans la rue de se retirer
d'ici une heure ceux qui sont en sit in
devant le parlement doivent partir sinon
je l'étais avant
les manifestations même pacifique
doivent cesser
habile ont tout de même 1 30 morts parmi
ses partisans et 570 blessés à l'origine
il ya eu l'annoncé par sa d'heure
c'était hier matin qu'il quittait
définitivement la vie politique de quoi
mettre en furie ses soutiens déjà très
remonté contre les autres factions du
pouvoir irakien mari roger ça montre le
pouvoir bien le potentiel de nuisance 1
dont dispose aujourd'hui un homme comme
moktada sadr en irak c'est vraiment le
mot et pouvoir de nuisance j'ai entendu
beaucoup dire
que il avait le moment le pouvoir
lorsque la demande d'un deux doigts de
mettre
tout un pays en émoi de créer des
émeutes etc mais j'aimerais bien voir
aussi comment il peut par son pouvoir
redresser un peu la positionne à la
situation politique de l'ira qui est
dans un une espèce de chaos depuis
pratiquement 2003 avec l'épisode conseil
de l'état islamique entre quitter le pic
mais on est on est jamais revenu à une
situation normale
depuis la mort de son père en 99 qui
était a été tué par saddam hussein ce
jeune homme qui a les retraites prévue
et n'a que 48 ans et en 1974 absolument
c'est un peu votre serviteur vous voyez
des jeunes vous êtes très jeune et on
voit le poids qu'il a le chaque fois et
l'envoi des gens paralysé l'assemblée
pourquoi parce que aux dernières
élections il a il est arrivé en tête on
le dit il a gagné l'élection pas
vraiment parce qu'il avait la lutte 62
73 sièges sous les 329 et arrive en tête
c'est pas vraiment gagner donc mais il
voulait que ce soit lui qui conduisent
l'assemblée il a fait une alliance un
moment donné avec numéro 2 ça n'a pas
marché et donc chaque fois il envoie ses
partisans paralyser tout le système
l'assemblée sont dans la rue mais
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas vu le côté
bénéfique positif de cette emprise sur
ses
partisans qui sont un peu fanatisés est
donc aujourd'hui ce monsieur
apparaît surtout quand un problème et
non pas une solution
ça montre aussi bilal travel et les
fractures du coran shit avec en toile de
fond le rapport à l'ancien premier
ministre nouri al maliki et surtout à
l'iran alors les fractures peut dire que
le mot est presque trop faible parce que
on voit en fait ce qui était jusqu'à
très récemment absolument inenvisageable
ce serait le scénario d'un affrontement
voire d'une guerre civile entre a shit
et je vais vous donner trois raisons
trois raisons crédible la première c'est
qu'on a déjà deux cons qui sont
identifiés qui sont antagonistes et qui
sont surarmés on a d'un côté ce qu'on
appelle le cadre de coordination chi
dont fait partie nouri al maliki et dont
font partie les milices armées par
téhéran des hashed achab et on a de
l'autre donc moktada sadr ses partisans
et aussi sa milice qui s'appelle les
brigades de la paix et hier lundi dans
ces affrontements on avait un scénario
où il y avait le mur autour de la zone
verte de bagdad on avait les brigades de
la paix dont la milice 2 al sadr qui est
rentré qui a réussi a dit vous voulez à
franchir les portes cette enceinte de la
zone verte et derrière on avait donc les
forces de sécurité irakiennes mais on
avait aussi une unité des milices tâche
à rasht achats mais c'est donc ce sont
d'autres ces deux fronts qui se sont
affrontés à balles réelles vous avez
donné le bilan d'une vingtaine de morts
la deuxième raison c'est la détestation
personnelle et profonde qui lie à entre
moktada sadr est donc nouri al-maliki
scénique c'est une détestation qui
remonte à 2008 quand maliki qui à
l'époque était premier ministre sous
l'ordre des américains a fait évacuer la
ville de bassora qui était occupé par la
milice de moktada sadr qui s'appelait à
l'époque l'armée du mahdi pour la petite
parenthèse maliki a réussi le tour de
force d'être à la fois copain avec les
américains est à la fois copain avec les
iraniens et enfin on a une troisième
raison est là elle est un peu subtil
mais il ya un combat identitaire au sein
des chiites en irak est de plus en plus
présent entre ceux qui veulent prêter
allégeance à l'iran donc les milices
haecht à schaerbeek et d'autres et ceux
qui prônent dont moktada sadr se veut le
représentant un nationalisme chiites
irakiens qui s'inscrit en fait dans
l'histoire de ce pays et sa cette
opposition elle est de plus en plus
frontale et elle est de plus en plus dur
c'est toute la difficulté pour l'irak
aujourd'hui marie roger se forger une
souveraineté à l'ombre de son puissant
voisin iranien et quand la majorité
cultuel de l'irak est elle-même shit oui
c'était un problème là l'iran l'ombre de
l'iran plane toujours même aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on vous dit comment on peut
réconcilier les deux france derrière les
pots et rannée hat et ceux qui se disent
nationalisme c'est encore il faut voir
c'est plus une posture
que qu'autre chose comment les
réconcilier la réponse une réponse au
lycée l'ayatollah ali sistani qui est en
iranien c'est le seul qui a vraiment eu
d'emprise sur les deux camps vous dites
on donc l'iran est extrêmement présent
et on le dit aussi il encore rien dit
comme si
voilà on attend la voix de l'oracle
et mais ça ce sont les jeux de pouvoir
les jeux d'alliance qu'il ya dans la
région elle l'iran à son arrière cour
voilà qui est assez importante notamment
et le gros morceau étant l'irak et et on
n'a pas vu jusqu'à maintenant une
influence moi j'insiste sous l'influencé
positive pour sortir du chaos c'est un
pays
qui à cet héritage depuis la deuxième
affaire la guerre menée par bush je
crois ça on est sensible à ça parce
qu'on voit ce que ça mais nombreux
succès le l'irak n'était certes pas une
démocratie où un pays heureux mais il
était stable et est ce que la situation
aujourd'hui est meilleure et on pense à
la libye par exemple on penser à la
libye et que ces guerres d'agression
comme en près de vingt ans après parce
qu'officiellement la guerre se termine
en deux mais on a déclaré la guerre
finie en 2003 on a aujourd'hui voilà on
a on n'a même pas une idée de comment on
peut régler sur le problème on peut
réguler revenir à une assemblée s'est
dit il faut dissoudre mais gens qui
disent non la solution c'est de faire
des élections oui mais lesquels encore
et s'il manque la da est en tête est-ce
qu'il va encore vouloir lui
façonner la l'assemblée selon ses
conditions et ses seules conditions dont
vous voyez on est on a pas de voie
tracée vers une solution stable c'est un
serpent de mer ce personnage parce que
il incarne une réalité pour une grande
partie de la riche idée pourtant il
n'aura jamais exercé le pouvoir non
alors il faut dire quand même que après
les élections législatives qui l'a
remporté
l'année dernière en octobre 2021 en fait
lui ce qu'il a dit c'est qu'il voulait
finir avec la culture de consensus et
former un gouvernement de majorité ce
qu'il n'a pas réussi à faire avec des
alliances ça il faut voir que c'est très
inhabituel
disons dans les pays du moyen-orient
dans les pays arabes qui disent on vivre
dans une structure démocratique vous
voyez la périphrase donc julia le liban
il y à l'irak qui sont des pays si vous
voulez qu'ils sont toujours plus ou
moins englué dans des conflits dans des
guerres civiles plus ou moins chaudes on
peut dire ça comme ça plus ou moins armé
est réel et il existe des sites voilà
qui décide si vous voulez finalement 2
de former leur gouvernement a à
l'unanimité constamment 2d gouvernement
d'union nationale mensuelle ça oui voilà
sauf que ça au bout d'un moment ça ne
marche pas quand on a des gens qui se
détestent et c'est le cas par exemple de
moqtada sadr et de et de nouri al-maliki
donc si vous voulez son idée de base
quoi qu'on pense du personnage n'était
pas si farfelue mais une majorité une
position qui une majorité et une
opposition exactement ça c'est s'il faut
savoir que c'est c1 c'est un jeu
démocratique que beaucoup que ce soit en
irak ou au liban et dans d'autres pays
refusent dans un système démocratique
donc effectivement
maintenant juste mais tous les camps
sont d'accord pour refaire des élections
par contre sont pas d'accord sur les
détails c'est lacombe au final voilà un
pays à cool ou la colère sociale qu'on
avait vu éclater ailleurs lors des
printemps arabes et même plus récemment
notamment au liban par delà les clivages
confessionnels c'est ce que beaucoup
avait relevé dans un pays comme le liban
n'a pas encore finalement en irak permis
de supplanter ces mêmes clivages mari
roger et bien oui est ce qu'on a
reproché à sa démarche il ya eu de la
colère sociale mais elle n'a pas
débouché encore une fois elle s'est
cantonnée au clan et au delà voilà ils
ont répliqué ce qu'avait fait saddam
hussein à qui on a reproché de l'église
et les chics je lisais des tartes de
tous et au profit des sunnites de la
petite minorité sunnite et la
maintenance ils ont sauvagement
systématiquement écrasé les sunnites et
on a vu ça donnait l'état islamique et
aujourd'hui maintenant que les sunnites
sont presque plus dans le jeu ces
rappels ils sont quand même entre eux
chute mais on n'arrive pas à trouver des
consensus et il ya une chose quand même
de moi qui me frappe c'est quelqu'un
comme moktada sadr qui parle beaucoup de
lutte contre la corruption n'est tout ça
ouais on a eu quand même le pétrole a
été
a été à un niveau très élevé le prix du
pétrole ils ont des budgets khanfar fans
nommé aujourd'hui si vous interrogez les
gens les audois n'y a pas de route via
pas depuis tôt affalé les structures de
base ils ont été incapables de médecins
sur pied poulet pour les populations
bien et il ya un risque de voir aussi
cette minorité sunnite qu'on n'entend
plus se radicaliser avec une résurgence
de vaincre de marie rose vient de dire
de toute manière la créat déjà faut
quand même rappeler que dice s'est créé
en irak à la suite de l'invasion
américaine par exemple si un cadre voilà
du régime d'assad amusé à une base des
baassistes donc des cadres des notables
sunnite mais avec aussi le concours
d'une trentaine de chefs de tribus d'une
région ouest de l'irak dans la plus
grande région ouest si vous voulez
qu'ils représentaient 70% de la
population sunnite de cette région et
c'était en réaction justement à une
vengeance des chiites contre eux depuis
qui depuis l'invasion américaine je
voulais simplement juste d'ouvrir un
site par rapport si on veut revenir à la
au mouvement touche rinne c'est à dire
d'octobre 2010 9 le soulèvement
justement d'une partie de la population
irakienne il faut quand même rappeler
la répression c'est à dire 600 morts en
trois mois dix sept mille blessés donc
c'est pas des conditions disons très
favorable à l'éclosion et un mouvement
pacifiste et pérenne beaucoup d'irakiens
fils pays les autres se taisent et voilà
dit les plus les plus fanatisés sont
dans la rue c'est ce qu'on voit autre
sujet du jour un vent de fronde qui
souffle sur l'angola où l'opposition
conteste les résultats officiels des
élections législatives ils ont vu
l'ancien parti unique de l'actuel
président joão lourenço l'emporter comme
toujours mais jamais d'aussi peu écoutée
elle toujours président dont commenté sa
victoire
unissons-nous dans un esprit renouveler
de patriotisme et de responsabilité
où chacun de nous apportera sa
contribution à une société plus juste
je serai le président de tous les
angolais et je m'engage à travailler
sans relâche pour que l'angola soit une
économie et une démocratie prospère on
m'a grandement cratie
face à lui et son parti le mpla l'unita
pour l'opposition ne reconnaît pas les
résultats et annonce donc déposé un
recours suspensif il faut dire bilal que
dans les autres servent acteurs
internationaux que des membres même de
la commission électorale ont fait part
de leur préoccupation quant aux listes
électorales à la fiabilité du scrutin
bah quand vous avez quatre des seize
membres de la commission électorale qui
refuse de signer le procès verbal
annonçant les résultats finaux c'est un
problème
ensuite parce que c'est une élection qui
est extrêmement surveillé enfin on cadre
il y avait à peu près 2000 observateurs
internationaux dans ces deux mille
observateurs internationaux on a ni plus
ni moins que les observateurs de l'union
africaine d'une part et de
l'organisation régionale qui sont les
états d'afrique australe d'autre part
qui ont fait part de leur préoccupation
après ces élections notamment à propos
des listes électorales ça il se faisait
écho si vous voulez à une pétition qui a
été déposée par une organisation qui
représente la société civile angolaise
dans le pays et au niveau de sa diaspora
qui qui en fait accuse si vous voulez
les organes responsables à l'état
d'avoir inscrit deux millions de
personnes décédées sur les listes
électorales faut quand même savoir qu'il
y avait 14 millions de dhs angolais
appelés aux urnes donc 2 millions sur 14
c'est pas négligeable d'autant que
d'autant que le parti présidentiel a
remporté l'élection de justesse à
51,2 mémoire et plus 51 17% des voix ça
en dit long
marie roger moore on arrive à la fin
d'un cycle avec les funérailles alors
concours de circonstances un de l'ancien
dirigeant autoritaire
josé eduardo dos santos ont pensé d'arc
inamovible à un temps décédé sans être
inquiétés a lui-même par la justice
angolaise et pourtant dieu sait si on a
pu lui reprocher notamment sur la fin de
son règne des malversations on avait cru
pourtant à son successeur prêt à
assainir le pays d'ailleurs il n'a pas
hésité à s'en prendre à une partie de
son ancien entourage il n'est pas allé
au bruit oui alors il ya une véritable
rupture avec joie ou du jour
il s'en est pris effectivement au à la
famille de dos santos son prédécesseur
koagne elle luttera choc je dois dire un
électrochoc à tous ceux qui pensent à
quitter le pouvoir et à trouver un
dauphin
ça a été très violent très brutal le
premier geste de de poutine savait était
de d'acquitter yalcin dans la nuit de
son sens son enfant exact de voir c'est
exactement l'inversé la celle inverse sa
fille il ya un des fils de santos en
prison
la fille a été
viré de tous les postes simplifie et
elle a des accusations sur le dos elle
vit en exil et beaucoup d'autres membres
de la famille ont été inquiétés est ce
ça qu'on lui a à la fois ça plus jamais
ça karim c'est un petit peu déplu parce
qu'on avait l'impression que c'était à
tête chercheuse vers la corruption ne
conserver qu'un certain nombre de gens
mais moi ce qui m'amuse dans le
processus actuel c'est que les
lendemains d'élections en afrique se
suivent et se ressemblent on a juste peu
de temps à vendre une bouteille du kenya
pareil on a eu une partie de la
commission électorale qui ont refusé
l'argument quitté la scène en disant ne
veut pas reconnaître son élection et les
2 0 et devant
[Musique]
odinga recours etc
et lisez les différentes réactions ici
et là on entend le plus en plus qu'on
arrête de vote en afrique ça sert à rien
puisque les résultats sont connus
d'avancé
et même là bon ça c'est déjà intéressant
parce que il ya eu quand même des
recours il ya on arrêtait on attendait
de confirmer tout ça la même chose au au
kenya mail ça va se terminer de la même
façon c'est à dire que ceux qui ont été
déclarés gagnants vont le rester ou le
devenir merci marie roger biloa merci
également à bill halter avis qui étaient
avec nous ce soir c'est la fin de ce
journal prochaine édition dans moins de
trois minutes rester avec nous dans
paris direct
[Musique]